i try
i try to live a normal life i didn't i
didn't do this for fame or wealth or
or celebrity status i did it because it
was the right thing to do
i did it was because it was what i was
trained to do even the military kept
telling the integrity first
service before self excellence in all we
do always tell the truth always do the
right thing you know
the same thing over and over again and
i'm doing it
and the people that are doing the wrong
thing just so happen to have
more power and influence and they can't
face me
publicly none of these p i've tr i've
talked to members of congress ted lau
who's in charge of the drone oversight
committee
you know they don't give a [ __ ] they do
not give a [ __ ]
how did you speak to ted lau i went to i
went to dc
and where where did you talk to did you
talk to him in person
in person in his office and what
sort of ideas did you express to him
and what were his reactions specifically
uh i expressed to him that what we were
doing is wrong and we need to
curb back and and start reassessing why
we're using this technology and he's
like
but isn't drones better at killing
people than boobs on the ground
or an f-16 aren't they more precise
aren't they more surgical and he was
just
he just gave me excuse after excuse for
why drones should be used rather than
listening to anything that i had to say
um what was your main concern that you
brought to him
was was it was it collateral damage no
my
actually my main concern that i brought
to him was how the people inside the
program are being treated and
abused and the consequence of that how
it
affects you know why people take the
shots why people
are angry why people are um
and and the leadership and and all that
type of stuff like i brought
more personal insider
stuff you know what people don't
understand is that i've gone up my chain
of command
like i've gone up my chain of command in
three
separate occasions i went to my
supervisor i went to my supervisor
supervisor i went to my flight commander
i went to my commander i went to my
first shirt i went to my d.o
of two different squadrons and then i
went up the civilian chain of command i
went up to
i went to senators i went to politicians
and
none of these people i went to
politicians in my own state
john tester and steve danes and asked
them if they would address this and if
they would
talk to me and help me and support me
and they told me directly that they do
not support or help people like me
so how i i'm a i'm a good american boy
i was a good christian boy who joined
the military
and him doing everything that he taught
i did everything right
i've done everything right you know
i i'm intelligent i
observe i am
thoughtful like i'm deliberate and like
i've tried to do everything right and so
the only way that i figured out to do
anything right
more is to do things on my own and to
talk to people like you
um actually more i'm more interested in
the academic side of it because i feel
like if more people are educated
ominous then those people that are
educated who are pursuing a route
in the legality of this or the ethics of
it will have the clout to stand
up eventually to say to stop this you
know yeah i totally i totally think
that's the right way to do it i'm happy
you're doing it that way
um talking to the right people
you know going to the right media
outlets expressing yourself in a
thoughtful
intelligent way um i i mean i've spoken
to the united states secure
the united nations security council like
i spoke directly to the u.n security
council in a private meeting
and told them all my concerns you know
but what really what power do they have
you know they can come out with a report
that says yeah the united states is
wrong and causing devastation all over
the world
but ultimately it's the united states
that has to do the right thing
right and then you know what is the root
cause of this we talked about the art of
war
right how do you how do you resolve
a conflict like this between nations how
do you create peace
obviously it's not dropping bombs and
killing tens of thousands of innocent
people
but but we the united states
doesn't want to create peace does it
it's this is a result of the industry
the military-industrial complex and
businesses making more money
and spending what was the the military
was it like a trillion dollars thing
congress passed for military spending
yeah recently i mean the core of the
problem
is wall street the lobbyists the
military industrial complex and i don't
know what the answer to that is
uh the answer to that is is to put them
all in prison
get bernie sanders in office yeah well
we need we need a second
bird yeah we well we actually i think we
need a second nuremberg
do you know what the nuremberg trials
were no so the nuremberg trials were
what happened after world war
ii the nazi trials okay so there were
the trials where the nazis were
you know i was just following orders
right
um there needs to be a precedent there
these people
need to be held accountable uh it's like
the
fact that um you know citizens united
how corporations are considered people
yes okay so the reason why that is
is because it means that the people that
are running the corporations i think
corporations are not people they're
vehicles for people to operate in
and if corporations are people then they
should be held accountable
the same accountability that an
individual is held accountable for
but because they're not they cannot be
you know
corporations can go under and then they
start up again under a new name
right and the people that are running
this and making these decisions
are not being held accountable they just
want money it's just greed
it's the same thing that's happening in
my town like we could be putting money
this taxpayer money to better education
better health you know better
environment
um you know but we have all these people
that want to develop montana because
they're coming from silicon valley
they're coming from new jersey new york
they're coming from seattle
and they want to bring the same
environment that they had over there
over to here but we have vastly more
limited resources than they do
we can't build on top of a hill here
because that means that we have to drill
a hole
hundreds of meters to get to the water
basin that is
that the aquifer that is below that
costs more money than actually
building the places that are that are
going up
but these developers want to build
high-rise condominiums here
so that they can densify my home
but they only doing it for money they're
not they're not taking into
consideration the people that
originally lived here it's colonization
it's colonialism
is what it is it's not even the
military-industrial complex it's
you got something that i want and i'm
going to take it
that's what it is um and these people
are evil
these people are evil like there's no
other word to describe it
they're evil do you think well joe biden
was elected president today he was sworn
in do you think there's any chance that
he could
help steer this ship away from the rocks
or that administration at all i mean
what do you think the difference is
going to be do you have
any kind of do you have is there any
glimpse of optimism inside you
um i feel like as
much as i feel very proud that kamala
harris
is our first female vice president and
not hillary clinton
i feel more a trepidation that we're
headed towards a police state a fascist
police state
rather than more freedom um i
s whistleblowed during the obama
administration when joe biden was vice
president
and unless joe biden takes a stand
against the military-industrial complex
and being like
we need to pull back we need to we need
to
like we're in a climate crisis right now
we don't even have 50 years left on this
planet if we don't get our [ __ ] together
and there are people that wanting to
make trillions of dollars
jeff bezos has made more money in the
last year than he's made his entire rest
of his career
and yet we have people starving and on
the street in a
homeless population that is growing
exponentially
we have more than four house empty
houses per homeless people
in the united states and yet it's more
profitable to keep those houses
empty for the banks than to allow people
to go in and move into them
right we have a we have a humanitarian
crisis that is building that will
probably
golf yemen pretty soon and yemen and the
stuff in the middle east was just
practice for these people to come back
and
do it over here
that's how i feel about it no sort of
optimism for the future
um well if if
people will take a stand then yes
and not in the not um my
you know i i listen to people to trump
supporters to try to understand them and
the q anon supporters and
even the anti-vaxxers it sounds like
those kind of q a non-supporters are the
same type of people that have the blog
the guy who
is against you that that sounds like the
kind of person
who was some of those people that
stormed the capitol last week
yep yeah and actually ryan neerson is a
is a q anon and trump supporter as well
um and uh even the people so the people
that got me to speak up against the city
council
i find out later that they're trump
supporters and q anon supporters as well
conspiracy theorists
and so i you know i'm not going to say
make speculation and be like all these
people are connected
but there are very similar there are
many similarities that i observe
in between behaviors and actions and
my military training i spent eight
months in training for observation
you know that's what my original job was
before drones was
being a intelligence operator that
observes
right observes and disseminates and
i feel like that was some of the best
training that i could have ever gotten
in my life
and on top of all the the healing and
self-work that i've done
it helps me like i can tell the
similarities between the actions that
are going on
and i can make those connections just
like i had been in training
you know these guys are you know
when people act in secret
eventually these things will come out
you know eventually people who act in
secret and think that they're gonna wait
get away
they're gonna get lazy and something's
gonna happen that is gonna expose it
but we see what's happening right now
things are being exposed all the time
and so more misinformation is being
thrown out there
and these people no longer care if
they're being exposed because they can
say something else and still get away
with it
because no one has the power to actually
stand up and do anything about it
who's going to stand up to the military
industrial complex
are you
i